[Music]
we've seen the cinderella story told a
dozen different ways but we've never
seen everyone's favorite underdog
princess like this this ella is a
princess made for 2021 and her movie has
some details that only adults will
notice
kids who aren't well-versed in music
history might think most of the music in
cinderella is original however the movie
is actually littered with many
delightful takes on 70s 80s and 90s
music the first song cinderella sings
isn't original to the movie at all in
fact it's a take on the 1994 song you
gotta be by r b artist desiree younger
audiences might recognize certain other
classic songs like prince robert's
version of queen's somebody to love or
vivian's rendition of madonna's material
girl less omnipresently popular songs
will probably elude them however but not
the adults in the audience who will be
jamming until the end the movie features
appearances from sultan peppa's what a
man earth wind and fires shining star as
well as jennifer lopez's 1999 hit let's
get loud which provides the last
show-stopping musical number original
songs like million to one round out the
soundtrack along with more recent
additions to the world's pop song book
prince robert and ella's charming slow
dance to ed sheeran's perfect is
especially memorable but otherwise this
movie is a masterclass in recent music
history if kids haven't heard these gems
before watching they'll certainly be
blasting them on repeat now
cinderella has a number of fairly
unsubtle innuendos we're looking at you
mice but princess laura's is especially
attention grabbing we'd expect nothing
less from the posh yet savage princess
we only get to know her for a few
minutes but she completely steals the
show in her dismal meeting with prince
robert during which she condescendingly
explains to him what a map is she tries
to arrange a mutually beneficial
marriage she leaves frustrated when
robert shows no interest in her proposal
even though she's perfectly chill with
him hanging out with his bros and never
spending time together except for when
they have to engage in what she calls
the disgusting practice of having a son
when she leaves the meeting in a huff
she gets the last laugh when she
addresses the other princess hopefuls on
her way out the door
it'll fly over children's heads but
laura's dig criticizes his desirability
from top to bottom from his brain down
to his well you know forget about
marriage laura's parting dig calls into
question whether or not this dense
prince would be worth a romp in the hay
at all
here is a sentiment every woman is tired
of hearing you'd be prettier if you did
x y or z
countless women throughout history have
dealt with this condescending compliment
while young girls certainly face their
fair share of criticism this particular
bit of nastiness is most often applied
to adult women women who tear other
women down out of internalized misogyny
also use this line something cinderella
vividly captures ella's stepmother
vivian constantly does this to her
stepdaughter never mind that vivian
forces her stepdaughter to live in a
dingy basement with only a few mice for
friends the misogynistic undertones of
most fairy tale-based movies are
prominent and it's refreshing to see a
modern take turn these tropes on their
head this creates a more positive
message and gives young women the tools
they need to call out this behavior
unlike most iterations of cinderella
this story's ella doesn't need to change
herself to win prince robert's favor she
catches his eye in a ragged dress and
messy hair even when ella prepares for
the ball she doesn't get made over into
a glamorous stranger she looks the same
in fact except she's wearing the dress
she designed it's an empowering choice
not everyone can be as subtle about
innuendo as princess laura but ella's
three best friends yes their mice try
their hardest when fab g turns ella's
mice besties into three human footmen
ella is confused to discover their mail
well that's not how that works ella
james corden's mouse human asks the
question on everyone's mind how do you
think rats have more rats fab g is quick
to steer the conversation away from
breaking the news to ella that mouse
babies don't get delivered by storks
things get even more uncomfortable after
the mice drop off ella at the palace
there james corden's mouse human makes
it weird again by announcing that he's
relieved himself from his
front tail
most kids watching cinderella likely
recognize idina menzel and camilla
cabello manziel voices elsa of frozen
fame and cabello is a famous pop star
but kids tuning into this might not
realize that billy porter is broadway
royalty porter hit the scene in the
early 90s when he played teen angel in
the 1994 greece revival more roles soon
followed culminating in the one that
made porter a household name in the
world of theater lola in 2013's kinky
boots porter originated this role and
garnered multiple awards including the
tony 4 best actor in a musical in the
process while certain teens might
recognize porter from american horror
story or pose even they might be
ignorant of his luminous broadway
history after watching cinderella
however they might be inspired to check
it out as porter is the perfect person
to take on the role of fab g he always
brings a unique pizzazz to any part he
takes on especially ones as glamorous as
this
most kids would rather enjoy the movie
than focus on its glaring plot holes as
it turns out fab g agrees with that
sentiment that said adults can't help
picking apart plot lines that don't make
sense even when magic is involved for
example fab makes it abundantly clear
that when the clock strikes midnight the
magic will wear off but despite the fact
that magic does eventually flicker out
of every single thing fab g bewitched
the glass slippers remain intact huh we
watch as ella's dress flutters away into
the wind the human mice turn back into
their four-legged selves and the
carriage transforms into a hunk of junk
yet days after the ball ellis still has
a fully intact glass slipper hiding in
her basket while prince robert has the
other one that's not the only odd thing
adults will notice either is ella's shoe
size really that special that no one
else matches it moreover the prince has
seen ella both dolled up and in tattered
clothes if the shoe fits an entirely
different woman is he really ready to
abandon everything he knows about ella
and runoff with a rando is he completely
face blind he doesn't even find her with
the shoe so this fairly nonsensical
plotline isn't even necessary
throughout cinderella the king seems to
be overcompensating for something his
frequent power trips aren't exactly out
of character for a king but his
particular preoccupations imply he might
be insecure about something only adults
will take notice of king rowan
constantly talks about the size of
everything around him characters bring
up the fact that he's had his minions
make his throne slightly larger not once
but twice this bit of innuendo gets a
laugh out of the older audience to be
sure but it also develops into a lesson
everyone can learn from we all have
things we're insecure about regardless
of our social status fame or fortune but
how we treat the people around us is
more important than whatever trivial
detail we agonize over despite the
king's self-consciousness he learns to
stop putting down his loved ones and to
respect and honor each of their
strengths regardless of the norms of the
time talk about character growth
whirlwind romances are the norm in
princess films but in reality it takes
time to get to know someone of course in
the eras that inspired the setting of
cinderella modern dating didn't exist
but an adult still can't help but flinch
at ella and prince robert's choices
proposing marriage after one date is
absurd and the prince is selfish to ask
her to give up her dreams however the
tables eventually turn when prince
robert gives up his dreams for ella's
sake but while robert may say that he's
not very interested in royal life or
becoming king he's making a very rash
decision at a young age that will affect
his life and the future of the kingdom
robert does at one point even tell his
father that there's nothing he wants
more than to be king he needs to give
himself a chance to mature into wanting
that role before running off with ella
lest he come to resent her there's no
denying that gwen is a better fit for
the throne and ella and robert don't get
married immediately but this is still a
case of someone a very young someone
giving up everything for another person
it's the prince instead of the princess
this time but it still demonstrates a
lack of foresight the grown-ups in the
audience will recognize as potentially
destructive
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you